[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you refer to the prophecy of the one who
will bring balance to the force you
believe it's this boy he can see things
before they happen he can help you the
force is unusually strong with him it
was man to ever see you again what does
it hard to tell you are you sure about
this trusting our fate to a boy we
hardly know Anakin Skywalker meet
obi-wan Kenobi I sense much fear in you
the boy is dangerous they all sense it
why can't you clear is the path to the
dark side fear leads to anger anger
leads to hate hate
it's just suffering
[Music]
[Music]
I will not let this Republic be split in
two minor goshi Asians will not fail if
they do they aren't enough Jedi to
protect the Republic
we're keepers of the Peace not soldiers
[Music]
sorry master I forgot you don't like
flying well you've lost him if you'll
excuse me I hate it when he does that
Anakin don't do anything without first
consulting either myself or the council
you don't need guidance Anakin I see you
becoming greatest of all Jedi has
exceptional skills his abilities have
made him arrogant excuse me I'm in
charge of security here milady
[Music]
we must stop them before they're ready
your clones are very impressive
they'll do their job well laughs that's
why I hate fly this is a crisis vote the
Chancellor emergency powers as my first
act I will create a Grand Army of the
Republic counter the increasing threats
of the separatists has been a full-scale
war since the formation of the Republic
we must join me everyone and together we
will destroy the Sith every danger you
are
[Music]
[Music]
began this corner
[Music]
[Applause]
dark side of the force is a pathway to
many abilities some consider to be
unnatural is it possible to learn this
power not from a Jedi the council wants
you to report on all the Chancellor's
dealings that's treason we are at war
and a container very dangerous putting
them together I don't think the boy can
handle it I don't just do I need your
help son I'm appointing you to be my
personal representative on the Jedi
Council you're on this council but we do
not grant you the rank of Master what
obi-wan and the council don't trust me
learn to know the dark side of the force
and you achieve a Power greater than any
Jedi you're under arrest Chancellor are
you threatening me master Jedi
[Applause]
every single Jedi is now an enemy of the
Republic do what must be done
do not hesitate show no mercy who
could've done this
twisted by the dark side young Skywalker
had become loose I feel so helpless
[Music]
you're the chosen one
[Music]
[Music]
the world is coming undone Imperial
flags rain across the galaxy
can you be trusted without your shackles
let's just get this over with shall we
we've a mission for you
a major weapons test is imminent we need
to know how to destroy
if you're really doing this I want to
help
[Music]
good I've been recruiting through the
rebellion for a long time we destroyed
our aside the Empire now
I fear nothing all is as the force
Wilson
the captain says you are a friend I will
not kill you
Thanks there is a much time every day
they grow stronger
there is a 97.6% chance of failure
a me as well
this is our chance to make a real
difference
are you with me
all the way
[Music]
Luke Skywalker was just a farm boy until
he received a mysterious message from a
princess she's beautiful
Star Wars starring Mark Hamill direct to
you which is short for a stormtrooper
Tennyson Ford Carrie Fisher
[Music]
Alec Guinness can't wind up if you
strike me down I shall become more
powerful than you can possibly imagine
20th Century Fox presents the most
extraordinary motion picture of all time
Star Wars
[Music]
no legendary adventure of the past could
be as exciting as this Romance of the
future may the force be with you in Star
Wars Luke Skywalker and Han Solo rescued
the princess destroyed the Death Star
but their story didn't end there
[Music]
now the creators of the biggest smash
hit of all time bring in the next
episode in the Star Wars saga The Empire
Strikes Back
[Music]
continuing story of our band of heroes
Luke Skywalker Princess Leia Han Solo
c-3po r2d2 and Chewbacca and introducing
Lando Calrissian it's an epic of romance
of heroes and villains they cross
trackless voids to unknown world
[Music]
a galactic Odyssey against oppression
[Music]
a big new sprawling space adventure in
the Star Wars saga The Empire Strikes
Back
coming to your galaxy next summer return
to a galaxy far far away read everybody
chew it see what this piece of junk can
do
here we go again
you will bring Captain solo and the
Wookiee to me
return to heroic adventure
you don't know the power of the dark
side return to the ultimate
confrontation love you
[Music]
return for the climactic chapter of the
Star Wars saga exciting as hockey the
word I would choose but most of all
return for the fun of it
Return of the Jedi who are you I'm no
one
[Music]
I was raised to do one thing
but I've got nothing to fight for
[Music]
nothing will stand in our way
I will finish
what you started
[Music]
there are stories about what happened
strong
Oh
[Music]
the dark side
a Jedi
[Music]
they're real
[Music]
the force it's calling to you
just editing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Bree
[Music]
just
[Music]
reach out like
[Music]
darkness
the barns
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I only know one truth
it's time for the Jedi to end
you